osorio territorio
en el límite de las aguas territoriales
griegas a más de una veintena de
emigrantes son rescatados por los
guardacostas turcos
así que habíamos llegado a grecia los
guardacostas llegaron botaron el motor
al mar nos golpearon incluso a las niñas
luego nos rechazaron hacia turquía
nos golpearon pincharon en bote que
empezó a hundirse
ese día la tripulación improvisada está
constituida de sirios afganos iraníes
somalíes e incluso congoleses más del
70% de las personas que quieren cruzar
ilegalmente a europa desde turquía
tratan de pasar por aquí el mar egeo
ankara acusa a atenas de incurrir en
dichos rechazos contrarios al principio
fundamental del derecho del mar que
indica que toda persona socorrida debe
ser desembarcada en el puerto más
cercano el 80% de nuestras operaciones
en el mar concierne en este tipo de
rechazos no muy lejos una embarcación
griega vigila las operaciones
grecia le avisa a turquía diciéndole
dónde debe intervenir y sus guardacostas
observan que los migrantes sean
socorridos así deban encontrarse en
aguas turcas
y territorios la lancha acelera y hace
una maniobra a alta velocidad para
repeler a la embarcación griega
contactado el ministerio griego de
asuntos exteriores rechaza cualquier
alegación de acciones ilegales y
considera que turquía no reacciona lo
suficientemente rápido cuando los
migrantes abandonan sus costas cuando
debe hacerlo según un acuerdo firmado
con la unión europea en 2016
y espera a veces hasta 24 horas antes de
asumir la gestión de los incidentes en
cuestión
las autoridades turcas permanecen
inactivas antes de que las embarcaciones
lleguen a la frontera
según la ong mar liberum 55 casos de
rechazo han sido censados durante los
tres primeros meses de 2001
cerca de 1.480 personas han sido
rechazadas 820 han llegado a las islas
griegas casi 10 veces menos que el año
pasado en el mismo periodo según cifras
de la onu
tras llegar a de kylie provincia de
izmir los migrantes son atendidos por la
óyeme que les da comida y ropa
le solicitamos a mohamed el sitio de
deir ezor quien lo ha intentado más de
una vez
si trataría de llegar a europa de nuevo
si si dios quiere claro que voy a tratar
de nuevo y si dios quiere esta vez lo
lograré registrados por migración turca
muchos lo intentarán de nuevo a pesar
del peligro según marx liberum al menos
12 personas han muerto o han sido
reportadas como desaparecidas debido a
los rechazos desde principios de año en
el mar egeo